[Musique]
les essentielles du sénat
le déclin des insectes mais l'humanité
en danger
libellule sauterelles et papillon nous
paraissent familier
mais jusqu'à quand
31% des espèces d'insectes serait
actuellement menacées d'extinction avec
une perte de l'ordre de 1 % des espèces
par an
en france les deux tiers des insectes
associés aux écosystèmes aquatiques et
humides se trouve dans un état de
conservation défavorable
l'office parlementaire d'évaluation des
choix scientifiques et technologiques a
publié en décembre 2021 une note sur les
causes du déclin des insectes et
alertant sur leurs conséquences pour les
écosystèmes et l'humanité
l'office relève que ce déclin s'explique
par de nombreux phénomènes en premier
lieu par l'agriculture intensive qui
entraîne une perte d'habitats naturels
ou semi naturels mais aussi par les
pesticides la pollution industrielle et
lumineuse le réchauffement climatique ou
encore l'invasion d'espèces exotiques
or les insectes 30 de nombreux services
dont dépend largement l'humanité tels
que la pollinisation le recyclage de la
matière organique le contrôle biologique
des ravageurs ou l'alimentation de
nombreux vertébrés
la disparition totale des pollinisateurs
entraînerait par exemple une baisse de
la production supérieure à 90% pour 12%
des principales cultures mondiales
la communauté scientifique est unanime
pour estimer qu'il existe un seuil de
rupture au delà duquel le déclin des
insectes entraînera des effets en
cascade irréversible
c'est pourquoi la conservation des
espèces d'insectes menacées d'extinction
doit être une priorité politique
explique la sénatrice annick jacquemet
rapporteur
face à ce constat l'opex t'identifies de
priorité
utiliser les bons leviers d'action pour
soutenir la transition agro écologiques
et accompagner les agriculteurs
en matière d'évaluation des risques liés
aux pesticides avant leur mise sur le
marché la rapporteur estime que la
réglementation est insuffisante
la politique agricole commune est un
levier d'action qui pourrait être
davantage exploité pour respecter les
objectifs de réduction de l'utilisation
des pesticides chimiques
à terme seuls les pratiques les plus
respectueuses de l'environnement devrait
être aidée économiquement
il convient parallèlement de former et
d'accompagner sur le long terme les
agriculteurs en intégrant la dimension
territoriale et en mobilisant tous les
acteurs en aval de l'agriculture
mais pas question de culpabiliser les
agriculteurs ni de leur soumettre des
injonctions contradictoires
l'office souligne l'importance de
veiller à la cohérence des leviers
d'action mobiliser politiques
réglementaires économiques ou
scientifique
pour en savoir plus consulter la note de
l'opex tu
[Musique]